das ist wirklich ein super spannender
und erstaunlicher nachweis einem us
forschungsteam ist es gelungen objekte
also große objekt ja
quantenphysikalischen miteinander zu
verschränken sie wurde zwischen zwei
winzigen aluminium trommeln eine
quantenphysikalische kopplung erzeugt
diese schwingen dann synchron im takt
und diese quantenphysikalische
verschränkung konnte dann sogar direkt
gemessen werden
pixum science in future hier gibt es
drei mal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
wie schon in meinem buch per aufzug in
den weltraum gibt es überall wo es gute
bücher gibt beschrieben habe die
quantenwelt ist auf dem weg in unserer
reale welt und damit sauber magie und
unmögliche phänomene okay das ist jetzt
etwas poetisch und unwissenschaftlich
aber irgendwie ist es tatsächlich so
nicht nur quantenrechner können mit der
quantenphysik erkenntnisse für die
wirkliche welt gewinnen konnten
verschlüsselte kommunikation gibt es
bereits die kranken welt sie
widerspricht all unseren erfahrungen aus
dem alltag und geht wirklich nur schwer
in den kopf scheinbar unüberwindliche
hindernisse können von elektronen und
anderen teilchen einfach so durch
tunnelt werden und atome können sich
vermeintlich gleichzeitig an mehreren
orten aufhalten das sind nur wenige
beispiele die große frage die trotz
intensiver forschung immer noch nicht
ein für allemal geklärt ist wo beginnt
das reich der quanten und wo hört das
auf gelten diese magischen gesetze der
quanten der kleinen teilchen
möglicherweise sogar auch für objekte
die wir menschen mit bloßem auge sehen
können und genau diese schwelle wurde
jetzt überschritten absolute gänsehaut
es gibt eine wirklich atemberaubende
erfolgsmeldung aus den usa den
physikerinnen und physikern ist es dort
gelungen typisches quanten verhalten
auch bei größeren objekten nachzuweisen
und das gelang ihnen mit relativ
ungewöhnlichen zutaten mini trommeln
nämlich gemeint ist die sogenannte
verschränkung an wirklich sehr seltsames
phänomen der quantentheorie zwei
verschränkte teilchen zeigen dass
absolut identische verhalten dabei
es ist ganz egal wo sie sind wie weit
sie von einander entfernt sehen das
können lichtjahre sein heißt also im
klartext wenn man die eigenschaft des
einen teils ließ steht zeitgleich
zeitgleich egal wie weit entfernt auch
die eigenschaft des zweiten teilchens
fest das alles passiert sofort und wie
erwähnt ganz unabhängig von der
entfernung egal ob die teilchen sich im
selben raum oder an den zwei
entferntesten ecken des universums
befinden
bei atomen molekülen oder anderen
teilchen der quantenwelt ist das für die
wissenschaft schon fast etwas
alltägliches geworden doch nun ist es
erstmals gelungen diese magische
verschränkung auch an größeren objekten
zu demonstrieren in dem aktuellen
experiment der us fachleute wurden also
die schwingungs muster von zwei jeweils
20 mikrometer kleinen aluminium trommeln
verknüpft eine echte premiere denn die
quantenphysikalische verschränkung
makroskopische objekte ist alles andere
als ein kinderspiel das ist tatsächlich
möglich ist objekt in dieser größe zu
verschränken und das dann auch noch zu
messen
das ist eine riesige sensation wie genau
ist das möglich wo liegt die obere
größten grenze für verschränkungen was
bedeutet das für die forschung und was
bedeutet das für unsere realität
bedeutet die neue erkenntnis
möglicherweise auch das
quantenphysikalische effekte auch auf
alltagsobjekte wirken ohne dass wir es
bemerken und nachweisen können fest
steht schon seit vielen jahren hat die
quantenwelt die wissenschaft in ihren
bann gezogen albert einstein ins tor und
erwin schrödinger gelten als die väter
der quantenphysik obwohl diese spukhafte
fernwirkung der teilchen die hat albert
einstein abgelehnt das phänomen der
verschränkung erlaubt es den zustand von
teilchen wie atom millionen oder photon
zu koppeln ganz egal wie weit diese
voneinander entfernt sehen und sobald
sich der zustand des ein teilchens
ändert gilt das auch für das verschenkte
partner teilchen und es erhält einen
zustand wechsel und genau das ist die
basis für viele super praktische
anwendung der quantenphysik so zb bei
quantencomputern ein team von google
hatte 2009 10 einen quantencomputer
entwickelt der mit 53 kubitz in 2 100
sekunden eine aufgabe gelöst hatte für
die ein gewöhnlicher supercomputer
tausende also an
computer tausende von jahren benötigt
hätte von wegen gewöhnlich also
quantencomputer rechnet anders als
klassische computer nicht mit bits die
den wert 1 oder 0 annehmen sie basieren
auf den sogenannten kubitz die beiden
werte gleichzeitig annehmen können sie
gehorchen halt der quantenphysik weil es
nur kleine teilchen sind und so viele
mögliche lösungen können sie dann zur
selben zeit durchrechnen
je nachdem wie viele von ihnen
miteinander verkoppelt sind weil das
eben nicht nacheinander geschieht
sondern gleichzeitig doch die
herausforderung dabei das system muss
quasi komplett von der außenwelt
abgeschirmt werden um zuverlässig zu
sein dazu schrieb der us physiker zur im
prestel nun da wir wissen dass die
technik funktioniert können wir mit der
suche nach nützlichen anwendungen
beginnen fachleute sind überzeugt davon
dass kanten computer schon in den
kommenden jahren regelmäßig in sehr
verschiedenen bereichen eingesetzt
werden können beispielsweise könnten sie
bei der entwicklung von neuen
medikamenten eine große rolle spielen
ebenso bei der entwicklung neuer
chemikalien und materialien eine große
herausforderung muss dazu noch
angegangen werden und zwar möglichst
fehlerfreies rechnen die fehlerquote bei
dem google experiment von 2009 10 lag
bei 0,5 prozent und je nachdem welcher
quantencomputer das ist können diese
werte durchaus im zweistelligen
prozentbereich und zwar im hohen
zweistelligen prozentbereich liegen und
dann sind die ergebnisse natürlich nicht
verwertbar aber hier in diesem fall das
war ein absolut sensationeller wert doch
die kanten physikalischer schenkung ist
auch die grundlage für banken
physikalische messmethoden und die
quantenkryptographie also die karten
verschlüsselung hierbei kann die
quantenmechanik eingesetzt werden um
informationen und den datenverkehr von
milliarden beiträgen auf elektronischem
weg sicherer zu machen schön und gut
doch einen haken gibt es bisher
denn bisher war die quantenphysikalische
verschränkung nur im reich der kleinsten
teilchen möglichst sogar lichtteilchen
und atom wolken mit winzigen
oszillierenden feder balken konnten so
in der vergangenheit bereits miteinander
gekoppelt werden
für objekte im makroskopischen maßstab
also ein auto einen tisch um mal sehr
groß zu denken zeigte sich die
verschränkung bislang allerdings als
sehr sensibel gegenüber umweltbedingten
störungen eine riesige herausforderung
denn objekte müssen dafür also
abgeschirmt werden von allen möglichen
einflüssen aus der umgebung die stören
könnten
und das wird umso schwieriger je
massereicher die objekte sind die
verschreckt werden soll nicht nur ein
vakuum sondern auch eine ganz besondere
kühltechnik sind hier notwendig vor drei
jahren 2018 gab es einen ersten
durchbruch dabei zwei forschungsteams
gelang es damals mechanische systeme im
mikrometer maßstab miteinander zu
verschränken konkret ging es in den
experimenten um oszillatoren paare deren
schwingungen jeweils
quantenphysikalische miteinander
gekoppelt waren beide systeme bestanden
aus millionen von atom und bewegten sich
damit an der grenze zur makro welt dazu
schrieb das forschungsteam aus
nottingham im jahr 2018
diese experimente bringen die
erforschung der verschränkung in ganz
neue bereiche es wird faszinierend sein
zu sehen wie viel größer solche
experimente in den nächsten jahrzehnten
noch werden können und genau dazu ist es
jetzt gekommen den wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern vom us national
institute of standards and technology in
boulder hatten mini trommeln ins visier
genommen um die quantenmechanische
verschränkung auch an größeren objekten
zu demonstrieren und das mit einem
bahnbrechenden erfolg zum experiment zum
einsatz kamen hier runde aluminium
membranen von je 20 mikrometern
durchmesser die die mini trommeln
bildeten die membranen haben eine masse
von je 70 piktogramm und bestehen aus
einer billion atom das klingt auf den
ersten blick erstmal nach nicht viel
doch für quantenphysikalische maßstäbe
ist das eine riesige menge die membranen
sind in der lage frei zu schwingen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nutzten mikrowellen
pulse und kühlten die membranen somit
auf den absoluten nullpunkt herunter
dann wurden die membranen verschränkt in
schwingung versetzt und eine
verschränkung dieser bewegung wurde
bewirkt in der fachsprache ausgedrückt
bedeutet das dass beide trommeln in
diesem zustand dann paare verschränkter
photonen miteinander teilten oder anders
gesagt ihre elementaren anregung muster
wurden verknüpft dem forschungsteam
gelang es zudem auch diese verschränkung
direkt zu messen und zwar mit der hilfe
weiterer mikrowellen pulse denn diese
werden von der membran reflektiert und
dann außerdem auch noch
stärkt dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
grob gesprochen messen wir die
korreliert zwei variablen sind wenn man
beispielsweise die position der
einkommen ist wie gut dann die position
der zweite aus dieser messung ableitbar
ist diese tests durchgänge wurden
insgesamt 10.000 mal wiederholt so
konnten die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler feststellen dass die
mini trommeln in ihren bewegungen
jeweils eine millisekunde lang
verschränkt waren und das ist in der
quantenphysik eine wirklich lange zeit
dazu schreiben die fachleute aus den usa
wenn man position und impuls beider
trommeln einzeln analysiert erscheinen
sie unabhängig voneinander aber wenn man
sie zusammen betrachtet sieht man dass
die vermeintlich zufälligen bewegungen
der ein trommel hochgradig mit der der
anderen korreliert ist dies geschieht
auf eine weise die nur durch eine
quantenverschränkung möglich ist heißt
also im klartext die beiden membranen
oszillieren tatsächlich eine
millisekunde lang perfekt in der phase
mit der gleichen frequenz wenn die eine
membran sich absenkte tat die andere das
auch damit ist den wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern also gelungen den
geltungsbereich der quantenwelt ein
stück weiter nach oben zu verschieben
und das eröffnet nach angaben des
forschungsteams ganz neue möglichkeiten
beispielsweise für anwendungen die etwa
empfindlichen quanten sensoren oder
quanten speichern dazu heißt es solche
verschenkten makroskopischen systeme
könnten für fundamentale tests der
quantenmechanik eingesetzt werden als
sensoren messung jenseits des kranken
dem mit erlauben und als langlebige
knoten in künftigen quanten netzwerken
fungieren
es bewegt sich eine menge in der kranken
forschungen auch hier fataler fehler in
der quantenphysik forschungswelt greift
verschmähte theorie wieder auf anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal mit dem knopf unter jedem
video das ist ganz einfach und kostet
nichts und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran